how often have we talked about this
where the left is in the business of
attributing motive and we go to great
lengths here to say listen I think
someone might just be misinformed I
think they're wrong before we assume
that they're liars I think this is a
great example of that let's drop Jimmy
Kimmel talked about his son who was sick
who through medical intervention was
saved and this is how I first saw the
story this clip it went viral and
everybody was on board let's watch he
got to the hospital very quickly they
did an echocardiogram which is a
sonogram of the heart and found that
Billy was born with heart disease so
this poor kid this is what he looked
like on Monday but this is what he
looked like yesterday and I think that's
great sure I think it's beautiful that
he was able to talk about I'm so happy
for his son when I first saw the story
that's all I saw I didn't see the
extended clip where he takes that and he
leverages his son's story to etcetera
etc etc by the way Trump sucks President
Trump last month proposed a six billion
dollar cut in funding to the National
Institute of Health and thank God our
congressman made a deal last night to
not go along with that they actually
increased funding by two billion dollars
and I applaud them for real you know
before 2014 if you were born with
congenital heart disease like my son was
there was a good chance you'd never be
able to get health insurance because he
had a pre-existing condition if your
baby is going to die and it doesn't have
to it shouldn't matter how much money
you make I think that's something now
whether you're a Republican or Democrat
or something else we all agree on that
right we all agree we should also all
agree on some facts that's true in the
United States it doesn't really matter
how much money you make what does matter
is if you live in the United States
because that's the single biggest
determining factor in whether that baby
lives or dies so this is again
attributing motive let's assume for a
second that um and we'll get into the
the ins and outs of socialized
healthcare and and medical research and
actually what comes from the private
sector versus the public sector but
let's assume for a second that there's a
debate to be had okay let's assume that
there's a conversation to be had that
well you know and so there's a lot of
medical research a lot of vaccines that
if
from the public sector and we can have
that argument you can have some
brilliant economists have that
conversation it still doesn't mean that
people who come on the other side of the
equation hate babies and want them to
die it doesn't mean that conservatives
Republicans are limited government
advocates want to see little babies
hauled out on many stretchers what it
means is we see a different way to more
effectively treat them we see a better
way to provide health care and we don't
see that like someone who was raised in
Canada someone who has watched bodies
put under the ground because of
socialized health care because of not
getting access to treatment in time for
necessary health care in the face of
terminal illness
I again I don't tribute every single kid
Makua I don't atribute to them motive
that they hate my aunt that they hate my
relatives who couldn't see a doctor for
their for their skin to find out what
cancer they had I just assume they're
incorrect but let's get into the math of
that that's important to note most valid
medical research takes place in the
private sector Berkeley themselves they
cite nearly 75% of clinical trials are
privately funded now let me sort of cut
you off with the past I know what
leftists are going to say here well yeah
but if you look all the vaccines all of
these cures they were all created before
modern privately funded clinical trials
the big medical industrial complex okay
AE American Enterprise Institute has a
great paper on this I highly recommend
you read it so it sounds like I'm
paraphrasing quite a bit of it here I am
but there are three eras of sort of
medical research in the United States
and you have sort of the first year
which is basically the Wild West let's
figure it out then you have the second
era where it's true the majority of
research came from publicly funded
institutions in the United States and
that's because at that time the publicly
funded institutions provided the
research and the private sector provided
the manufacturing horsepower that they
knew the government couldn't so it kind
of think like a war effort only instead
of tanks and Nazis polio and vaccines
those that was a relationship back then
as a matter of fact Franklin Roosevelt's
a science adviser Vannevar Bush called
in 1945 for a sharply increased federal
investment at research
Bush's entreaty entitled science the
endless frontier emphasized the
importance of basic research unlinked to
practical ends as the best route to
innovation and this is important here
for people who might miss this this is
why
can find numbers that seem to be
conflicting this this when you're
talking about this this sort of I guess
entreaty is what it's called I want to
give a technical term right when you're
talking about this it's basically
increasing funding for research with no
means to an end it doesn't necessarily
have to mean medical research biological
medical research then this we have to
have a means to an end in the terms of
finding a cure to a disease or finding
any treatment to a disease by and large
the purpose of medical research in the
publicly funded community in the
academic community is to impress
academia with your published research as
a matter of fact you'll find numbers who
will look at all this research conducted
in the in the public sector a lot of
that doesn't directly rate relate to
medicine at all and certainly not
biological medicinal research that would
lead to treatment of diseases that's why
the numbers might not bear out if you do
some research because by 1990 corporate
investment medical research actually
exceeded that of the public sector it's
now over twice as large three separate
analysis concluded that 85% of the drugs
approved by the FDA since 1988 arose
solely from research and development
formed within the industry so I know I
know you're gonna take your cumin smoked
your pot you don't believe in drugs
that's fine this isn't the video for you
the USA accounts alone so when you
compare it with socialized healthcare
countries they account alone for 30% of
global research and development in the
medical community
the US has way more MRI units per
patient remember when I was in in in
Quebec you'd have to wait over a year to
get an MRI I think it was something like
10 to 20 times the amount of MRIs there
were only ten in the entire country and
I'm talking about in the early 2000s
when I was raised in Quebec emergency
rating waiting room times people who
waited for over five hours in emergency
room in Canada it's over 19% in Quebec
it's over 35% so again if we're going to
talk about motive which is what the left
wants to do with Jimmy Kimmel listen
it's really easy to take a personal
story and say you know can you believe
that Donald Trump listen your son wasn't
saved by medical research that was
created from a grant from Barack Obama
your son was very likely saved from for
medical medical advancements that
occurred under a free enterprise society
thanks to capitalism and people who had
some kind of
ambition some kind of incentive to go
forth and innovate and the fact that we
say we should create in an atmosphere
for more medical innovation by let's say
lowering corporate tax rates by let's
say creating economic incentives rule is
the fact that we say you know what let's
create an atmosphere for more of that
doesn't mean that we hate children maybe
it means that we just understand a more
effective way to treat them than you
knew and I could trot out a personal sob
story I could say you know what my aunt
took her eight weeks to even see a
doctor when they saw a spot of lung
cancer on at that point it already
metastasized and it took another four
weeks for them to even determine what
kind of treatment she could go going
forward and because it was advanced she
effectively sat in front of death panels
I know people say there are no deaths
they're not called death panels but when
you're under socialized healthcare guess
what they have to ration health care
because it's at the taxpayer expense
they don't have a whole lot of it and if
you're facing a terminal illness and
your only chance is some experimental
medical treatment you're out of luck and
a bureaucrat decides whether you live or
die I could take that anecdotal story
and just tell you that socialized health
care completely sucks I would argue that
but not because of that anecdotal story
but because of all the research that
I've provided again don't be in the
business of simply questioning motives
even people who are going to be
commenting in the comments section here
if you're going to argue argue from a
technological perspective of medical
advancement argue from a statistical
perspective I'd love to see that
argument I can see both sides but not
because something sad happened if you
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if you're
not aware of it now there's no way
you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand etched mug oh I just when I
feel it I got a chill like on the inside